. The latest in the conga line of corona virus
infections can get connected to the White
House.
Is Donald Trump's own press secretary, Kaley
McKenny.
We just saw video of Rudy Giuliani unable
to stop coughing during a Fox News interview.
He is waiting on his latest test results for
Corona virus.
We may have gotten those results by the time
you watch that clip or this clip.
But someone who did test positive is White
House Press Secretary Kaley McEnany and two
of her deputies have tested positive for the
corona virus as well as Donald Trump has now
left Walter Reed Medical Center, presumably
still contagious.
First Lady Melania Trump remains in isolation
with coronavirus.
She reportedly doesn't want to spread it to
the Secret Service agents who she would be
exposing if she were to try to go anywhere.
Kaley McEnany putting out a statement via
Twitter which says, quote, After testing negative
consistently, including every day since Thursday.
It's funny how they always say that, like,
listen, everybody who gets Corona virus test
would have tested negative for a long time
until they test positive.
OK.
After testing negative consistently, including
every day since Thursday, I tested positive
for Kova 19 on Monday morning while experiencing
no symptoms, no reporters, producers or members
of the press are listed as close contacts
by the White House medical unit.
Moreover, I definitely I definitively had
no knowledge of Hope Hicks his diagnosis prior
to holding a White House press briefing on
Thursday as an essential worker.
I have worked diligently to provide needed
information to the American people at this
time.
That's funny.
The idea that her lies are essential.
With my recent positive test, I will begin
the quarantine process and will continue working
on behalf of the American people remotely.
Now, this is a.
Picture of her just days ago briefing a gaggle
of reporters without a mask on, and it simply
continues to spread.
At the White House, she was criticized for
briefing reporters without a mask.
Hours after Donald Trump tested positive.
The defenders came out and said they were
socially distend.
She was she took the mask off only when she
was not near reporters well, for the entire
week during which she was likely contagious
or part of that week.
She wasn't wearing a mask at all.
The masks started later on in the week.
We, of course, have numerous others connected
to Trump who have tested positive.
At this point, it's hard to even keep track,
but it includes Trump's own campaign manager,
Bill Stepien.
Republican National Committee Chairwoman Ronna
McDaniel, Trump adviser Kellyanne Conway and
Kellyanne Conway's daughter, Claudia Conway,
have tested positive.
New Jersey Governor Chris Christie tested
positive.
Three Republican senators I mentioned yesterday,
Mike Lee of Utah, Thom Tillis of North Carolina,
who's up against that?
He may be about to get beaten badly by Cal
Cunningham in North Carolina, a Wisconsin
Republican, Ron Johnson.
Nick Luna, who's a personal assistant to Donald
Trump.
The University of Notre Dame President John
Jenkins tested positive.
He was at the Amy CONI Barrett event not this
past Saturday, but the previous one at the
White House, which does appear to be a super
spreader event.
At least three journalists who were at the
White House over the last week have now tested
positive, according to the White House Correspondents
Association.
Remember when Kaley McEnany said on Fox News
back in February the following?
Absolutely.
This president will always put America first.
He will always protect American citizens.
We will not see diseases like the corona virus
come here.
We will not see terrorism come here.
Isn't that refreshing when contrasting it
with the awful presidency of President Obama?
Candy?
McEneaney, thank you so much.
Good to see you.
Thank you.
So that was a ridiculous thing to say then.
And it's even more ridiculous to say it now
that Donald Trump has it and she now has tested
positive.
It is the fascinatingly dystopian secondary
story.
So you've got how has this administration
handled coronavirus?
That's a primary story.
It's immoral.
It's disgusting.
And it's infuriating how they handle it.
When they themselves get the virus is arguably
more absurd, although not connected to as
many deaths, because remember that this either
began or was exacerbated by a party in the
Rose Garden as well as inside the White House,
where hundreds of people sat shoulder to shoulder
without masks, hugging, talking inches from
each other's faces.
Caylee, along with numerous other people like
William Barr, have continued to make public
appearances with no masks, knowing they were
exposed to people that tested positive.
No contact tracing has been done.
We learned that Joe Biden's campaign was not
contacted as people started testing positive,
including Trump to say, hey, this happened,
isolate, test, quarantine, whatever you need
to do.
They've been deceptive about the timelines.
It has been asked now nearly a dozen times.
When did Donald Trump last test negative?
They won't tell us directly, implying that
Trump either new or suspected he was contagious
during the debate with Joe Biden, that their
claim on the honor system, that Biden, rather,
that Trump tested negative on the day of the
debate.
He probably wasn't tested at all.
And so aside from never doing that crazy Amy
CONI Barrett event at the White House, everybody
here involved should have immediately self
isolated for 14 days when Hope Hicks got sick.
That alone would have reduced the transmission.
But they either don't care or are unwilling
to do the right thing for other people.
It is stunning.
They deserve a historic loss in November,
not only for their personal responsibility
as leaders, but because they've overseen one
of the worst responses in the world to the
virus, which is now surging again in many
states.